sería bastante desagradable que en un
futuro quedáramos mal por algún tipo de
pájaro que hable así que sería muy bueno
que practicamos cómo resolver sistemas
de ecuaciones por el método de
sustitución y en este caso tengo
resuelve para el que sigue mediante el
método de sustitución y aquí tengo dos
ecuaciones menos x menos igual a 1 x es
igual a menos tres menos 9 y bueno pues
justo aquí acabo de copiar esas dos
ecuaciones aquí en mi bloc de notas así
que vamos a trabajarlas justo por aquí
dice menos x menos igual a 1 x igual a
menos 3 yemas 9 ahora quiero que te des
cuenta que cuando nos dicen que
utilicemos el método de sustitución lo
que tenemos que hacer es despejar una de
las dos variables y sustituirla en la
otra ecuación en este problema ya no
están dando despejado a la variable x
nos dicen que x es exactamente igual que
menos 3 y menos 9 es decir que puedes
sustituir este valor de x este valor que
tengo aquí en mi primera ecuación
puede ser es bueno porque recuerda que
al final lo que buscamos es un valor
para x y un valor para ello que cumplan
ambas ecuaciones por lo tanto está x el
valor que tome esta x en esta ecuación
de abajo va a ser exactamente el mismo
que el valor que va a tomar x en esta
parte de arriba por lo tanto puedo
sustituir y es master que me puedes
decir puedes sustituir a x a esta x de
aquí por este valor que tengo acá porque
tiene que ser la misma x y ahora sí
utilizando un método de sustitución lo
que hay que hacer es sustituir el valor
de x que ya tenemos despejado en este
caso en la otra ecuación en donde no
tenemos despejado a x y creo que te des
cuenta que ahorita que reemplacemos el
valor de x por menos 3 729 en la primera
actuación entonces nos va a quedar una
ecuación que solamente depende de ella
es decir me va a quedar que esta primera
ecuación la pobre de la siguiente manera
lo voy a poner aquí menos x pero x vale
o bueno pero x vale menos tres y menos
tres a menos nueve entonces me va a
quedar menos
x pero x vale menos 3 - 9 y como sé eso
es la información que me da la segunda
ecuación ok esto - james tiene que ser
igual a 1 estoy utilizando la ecuación
de arriba y estoy sustituyendo el valor
de x y ahora si me quedaría a dejar
ponerlo con este color menos x menos más
me va a quedar 3 y menos por menos más
nos va a quedar más 9 - jeff esto es
igual a 1 o dicho otra manera
3 - es lo mismo que dos veces más 9 esto
es igual a 1 o dicho de otra manera si
yo restó 9 de ambos lados de esta
ecuación voy a restar 9 aquí voy a
restar 9 aquí entonces y de este lado
estos dos se van a ir y me queda que 2
es igual a 1 - 9 129
es lo mismo que menos 8 o 9 menos uno
con signo negativo ok y ahora si yo he
vivido todo entre dos esta parte entre
dos y esta parte también entre dos estos
dos se van a cancelar me va a quedar que
y es igual a menos cuatro menos ocho
entre 12 menos 4 y ya tengo el valor de
y de lujo ahora recuerda que no hemos
acabado lo que necesitamos también es el
valor de x y para encontrar el valor de
x puede utilizar la ecuación arriba en
la ecuación de abajo pero en la ecuación
de abajo ya tengo despejado a x por lo
tanto qué te parece si la copiamos aquí
x es igual a menos tres y menos 9 y
sustituimos el valor de 10 que es el que
ya tenemos es decir que x es igual a
menos 3 por james pero ya habíamos dicho
que vale menos 4 menos 4 y todo esto
menos nueve menos nueve ok
dicho de otra manera x es igual a más 12
34 es 12 menos por menos es más
- 9 o x es igual a 3 de lujo x es igual
a 3 y es igual a menos 4 y vamos a
corroborar en las dos ecuaciones a ver
si en efecto llegamos a la solución
comprobemos en la primera ecuación
- x o es me va a quedar menos 3 menos y
es menos pero lleva al menos cuatro
menos cuatro esto es igual a 1 ok y aquí
lo que daría que menos tres más 4 es
igual a 1 lo cual es cierto 4 - 3 es uno
de lujo y vamos a probar en la segunda
actuación dice x es decir 3
es lo mismo que menos 3 por james que
vale menos 4 ok menos 9 y aquí me
quedaría que 33 es igual a 12 positivo
menos 9 lo cual es cierto entonces se
cumplen las dos ecuaciones cuando x vale
3 y vale menos 4 se cumplen ambas
ecuaciones vamos a escribirlo aquí en
nuestro navegador de internet así que lo
voy a poner aquí x3 de igual a menos 4x
igual a 3
igual a menos 4 ok y es hora de
comprobar respuesta comprobemos de lujo
estamos bien nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo